i can tell you about this it's not a  secret as far as i know uh we i mean  each each player has to uh do the self  test before the round  and i mean obviously i kept doing them  and they were always negative  and then it was uh yesterday when i did  the  um  i mean i had to go for uh for pcr in the  morning so i went uh  i mean i went  for pcr  as a result had to had to come in this  afternoon but he came like way later  then i did the self-test it was negative  again and then  like almost at night they called me and  said congratulations you're positive  yeah  this is how it works  once again the way is the way i  understood it has to be  it has to be like five or seven days  since you since you failed the  the first symptoms  then i don't know i mean i still feel  great but if you look at my games  against jordan and grandelious it's very  symptomatic now  kind of yeah yeah so i mean i yeah  it really depends on the way you're  on where you start counting